china is behind a huge cyber attack of
microsoft microsoft is in the middle of
a cyber attack uh cyber crisis right now
hackers targeted weaknesses in microsoft
exchange service which is used by small
and medium-sized companies
the attack allowed hackers to access the
email accounts of at least 30 000
organizations in the us and has affected
hundreds of thousands of microsoft
customers around the world
microsoft flat out said the hack came
from a group tied to the chinese
government called
hafnium the biden administration is
launching an emergency task force to
address this aggressive cyber attack the
second major hacking
campaign to hit the us since the
election as this comes on the heels of
solar winds a separate series of
sophisticated attacks
attributed to russia that breached about
a hundred u.s companies and nine federal
agencies tom thoughts
um we are living in a cold war now and
it's being fought
in digital pipes it's as simple as that
and
china and russia are trying to assert
themselves
as the new duopoly of world power and
they're going after things that matter
and so if anybody doesn't think
that we're in a cold war right now
they're not paying attention
we may not be putting pushing missiles
in germany to
take down the berlin wall and things
like that but we are in the middle of a
cold war and people need to pay
attention to it
yeah we brought it up on the last
podcast that uh you know i think it was
with den
with danielle dimartino booth and i said
look we've been talking about china
we're talking about china
at what point are we like is like the
alarm bells are gonna go off
you know trump kind of signaled some of
the alarms with the trade war but that
was more about soybeans than
actual intellectual property but the ccp
you know they are they are enemy number
one and i've
we've addressed it and i've kind of just
hitting this home and hitting this home
there this is enemy number one and uh
we talked about it last time that the
problem in america right now is that
we're fighting amongst ourselves
and we have to um rectify that come to
terms with that and start fighting
against
who our real enemy is which is china
coming after our
everything we got so yesterday i talked
to the former director of cia james
woolsey
i had them on okay big name back in the
day big name back in the days
he was hired by bill clinton he was a
director of ci if you remember
the the the uh the one individual that
we had was a former cia agent of 31
years that turned against u.s and
the espionage and what was the last name
amit or
uh i can't think of his last name and uh
he turned against the u.s
and he was a director of ci when that
even took place okay back in 1994 i want
to say
february when when that came out and it
led to james was right there aldrick
ames
is who was a former ci agent that ended
up becoming a kgb
um spy and helped out for them and
shared a lot of intel with them right so
we talked about different countries and
he brought up china and he brought up
russia and we brought up you know a
bunch of different things that we're
talking about
i said what's your biggest concern and
threat that we have right now
uh uh on how they can attack us give me
a creative way
he said the electro magnetic pulse
emp right it was the first time this was
ever brought up in a
uh debate was by newt gingrich when in
2011 2012 in a presidential debate they
asked what is the biggest threat that we
should worry about
he said emp electromagnetic pulse and
everyone was like uh
let me go to google what the hell is an
amp right so
look um you know
you notice two stories russia targets
what
twitter china targets who microsoft
microsoft
okay and uh what is the real
long term ramifications control threat
if somebody decides to because
what an emp is they drop it a mile
above you and it it kind of explodes but
it's not a bomb it's not anything
and all of a sudden it takes out all
your electric
powers all the plants go ahead remember
ocean's 11
yeah exactly it's a very small glimpse
of it yeah where don cheadle's up there
with that big hole
yup big battery and he covers up his uh
manhood and presses the button
that's an emp it takes out all the
electricity in the entire town of las
vegas so this can take it out
in the entire country if they wanted to
right emp so
remember how i said you know what can
russia really do to twitter
if they really wanted to some of these
empires they're not held accountable to
u.s
it's not like their accountability is to
them what can they do and who can they
blame
are you going to pull them over give
them a ticket so no cops on your nation
i think things are getting very
interesting i think things are getting
very very interesting and by the way
none of this stuff is new none of it is
new on what's going on but
uh is it about to get to a level where
you know
some some crazy stuff's gonna happen
where we're gonna get a real real
experience of what it is because what
happens if we lose electricity for a
month
imagine you have no power then what
happens chaos what kind of chaos
how long can it last how long is it
sustainable
how long can the generators last what
happens once the generators are gone
what happens to the people that don't
have generators
who do they go to what happens to the
people that have generators do they keep
it a secret what happens
how long before we recover from it how
long before we come back up from it it's
very very interesting
uh on what's happening today and what
i'm trying to say to the listeners i'm
very optimistic about it yeah
your future looks very very bright
future looks very bright but we're
hoping that people
will play nice and they'll find a way to
be diplomatic amongst this amongst each
other
and uh somehow someway realized that at
the end of the day
if you do something to another person it
can backfire in another way and i'm
hoping that's the one part that gets
people
to not go to the craziest routes of
doing dumb things small things like
microsoft twitter maybe that can happen
i just hope it's not the level of
retaliation with the retaliation keeps
getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger so
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye